let's bring in our panel byron york
chief political correspondent of the
washington examiner juan williams is a
fox news analyst and bill mcgearn
columnist for the wall street journal
byron your thoughts on what you've heard
from the administration and what's
happening
well it this is just a terrible terrible
situation we're not flying as many
people out as we have the capacity uh to
do
we don't know how many americans there
are outside
of kabul of the kabul airport throughout
afghanistan we can't go get them because
we don't control anything outside of the
airport the president the defense
department the state department and the
intelligence community are all pointing
fingers at one another and the worst
thing of all is that we are dependent on
the good graces of the taliban it sounds
crazy to say it we're dependent on the
good graces of the taliban to do
anything there so it's a very very bad
situation
you know just earlier in the show i
asked john kirby about that because in
fact the british are did do this and
have been doing this paratroopers have
been going out collecting british
british citizens in shelter in place
different places throughout kabul
here's that i asked kirby about it
why is it left to the americans outside
of that ring
to get there on their own why can't we
send vehicles to go get them we
we have not seen
any great impediments
to the safe passage that the taliban
have agreed to facilitate americans are
getting through those checkpoints and
they are getting on to the base on the
airfield and they are being flown out of
kabul i won't speak to potential future
operations that may or may not be
conducted
juan what do you think i mean
anecdotally we hear tough times getting
through taliban checkpoints
well i think if you or i were there i'd
be concerned i don't think there's any
question if our loved one was there
you've got to worry you can't trust the
taliban in my opinion but look i think
that you know
this when we what we're talking about
here is the evacuation and there's no
question it could have been done better
it's being badly handled on so many
levels
but i don't think that
no matter how the evacuation was handled
that the big picture which is could the
afghan government have held could the
afghan military have
held its own and not folded i don't
think those things would have turned out
much differently if you recall
president trump secretary pompeo wanted
out by may 1st biden wants out by august
15. i think in either case those big
picture items the brass tax of this
would have been much the same
you know i think that's why that poll
that jackie heinrich mentioned earlier
is so true two-thirds of the american
people say this war was not worth
fighting majorities of both democrats
and republicans so when you look at it
in those terms i think we can quickly
quickly say yeah you know once the
american troops and the americans are
out i think this is all going to be
forgotten
but bill you know the the big picture is
not that we wanted to get out of the war
the big picture is how we got out of the
war now we have this wall street journal
report about two dozen uh kabul embassy
officials sending a memo uh to the
secretary of state saying that they are
seeing the taliban on the move and this
thing is going to collapse very quickly
the second that american troops leave
that seems like a warning now it's not
before they leave but it is
a warning that the things are happening
quickly
yeah look the biden administration is is
maintaining two contradictory things one
is joe biden says that we would have
this chaos with any retreat and that we
saw
um you know you can and then he says no
one told them about it beforehand we're
likely to find a lot more of these kind
of uh warnings going i push back on the
larger picture you know for some reason
uh we've we've had we have had three
presidents that have have concluded they
don't want to fight in afghanistan our
combat role was largely done
and it seems to me that the definition
of failure we have that because in 20
years we didn't
transform afghanistan into belgium uh
you know a functioning democracy you
know where rights are largely respected
means that it's a failure i mean
afghanistan was a a lot better for
people under even under this uh the
corrupt afghan government certainly
better for women certainly strategically
better for us unlikely to give safe
havens the way al qaeda and again it
would have required a minimal
uh presence to do it this was a
catastrophe it seems to me pretty
obvious willed by joe biden he made the
decision he came in
advocating that he is the smartest guy
in foreign policy knows all this stuff
and i think he overruled some of his own
advisors and so forth he wanted out he
wanted out by 9 11 to have an
anniversary and uh and that's what
that's what we have and now now that
they've screwed up so largely they want
to present this as
inevitable but i mean just think about
what we're seeing the images not just at
the airport you're going to see a
taliban flag flying over the u.s embassy
in kabul on the 9 11 anniversary the
20th anniversary of 9 11.
you have billions and billions of
dollars of u.s military equipment
humvees black hawk helicopters
big armored vehicles that are now in the
hands of the taliban which john kirby
cannot say to me today whether they
consider them an enemy or not just got
word byron from state department that
the u.s will not charge for evacuation
flights saying in these unique
circumstances we have no intention of
seeking any reimbursement from those
fleeing afghanistan so they have that
going for them if they can get to the
airport
yes if they can get through the taliban
checkpoints to get to the airport now
this this report
in the wall street journal
in which the state department basically
predicted an instantaneous collapse of
the afghan government the thing that
that it seems to me that that report
means uh is that it would require a lot
of planning ahead of time to get people
out get people out have a whole process
going
before
before you finally
leave send you take the military out now
president biden said he couldn't do that
because the the afghan government didn't
want it because it would the optics
would be bad and there'd be a crisis of
confidence i want to learn more about
that i think that's that's a real
possibility here
but if you have uh people on the ground
u.s government officials on the ground
saying in afghanistan saying look
there's going to be an instantaneous
collapse in this place the the
decision makers have to take that
seriously yeah
i want to play this one sound but last
person in the room this is vice
president harris
president biden always said that he
wants you to be the last person in the
room particularly for big decisions just
as he was for president obama he just
made a really big decision afghanistan
yes
were you the last person in the room yes
and you feel comfortable i do
the new york post where's kamala last
person in the room harris silent days
six days in mid-afghan pull-out chaos 10
seconds juan where is she
i think she's pretty invisible but i
think that's the way most vice
presidents are and if you recall biden
was that for obama in terms of going
after bin laden he even objected to it
so you know
that's right